hello again time then for the press
preview a first look at
what is on easter sunday's front pages
in the next
20 minutes or so we'll see what's making
the headlines with the journalist and
author rachel shabby
and the daily telegraph leader writer
tim stanley a very happy easter to both
of you speak to them in a moment first
of all let's have a quick look at the
front pages starting with the sunday
telegraph revealing
that covid passports designed to return
life to normal in britain might not be
ready until the autumn
the sunday express also leads with prime
minister's vaccine passport plans saying
they won't be needed in pubs
yet foreign holidays on track to start
may the 17th is the headline in the mail
the times leads with concerns that more
than 200 000 pupils will move from
primary school to secondary school this
autumn
without being able to read properly due
to interrupted learning during covid
the observer hears that shakir stamina
has told the labour party to prepare for
an early general election in may 2023
and the star features yuri gellar
challenging readers of the paper to
fix the royals with their minds
and we're joined tonight by rachel
shabby and tim stanley great to see you
both let's start tim
with your paper the sunday telegraph in
fact all the front pages
feature the passport idea the kovid
passport and in fact they all have to
say
seem to be pretty positive the sunday
telegraph
has an interview with michael gove who's
been looking into this issue
their headline passports to normal life
but not
for months so uh the suggestion being
it's not something that's around the
corner tim
first of all i just have to say i don't
know if i would call the telegraph
coverage positive
it's simple objective at this stage
it's the story has just broken the i'm
not saying the prime minister is going
to announce the future of the covet
passport uh it's not called the covert
passport apparently it's called covet
certification but it won't be a
certificate
it's probably going to be a an app on
your mobile phone
and probably won't block by you from
getting into pubs and restaurants
it's most likely going to be used for
big events and will be trialled over the
next
few weeks so you'll get this app and the
app
will show that you have had a test that
has shown you are negative
the app would show that you have the
unionized or the outgo that you
ranked over it within the last six
months
now one interesting detail the telegraph
has which i don't think the other papers
do have
is questions coming out of whitehall how
long it would actually take to develop
this
app and it's possible that it won't be
ready to be rolled out on a mass level
until about september or later this year
which is going to raise an interesting
political question
one point of giving us covert
certification
if the vast majority of adults by that
point have
immunized is this like track and trace
some have said
a big waste of money a white elephant
something we don't need to do
and also some tory backbenchers don't
like it for civil liberties
reasons also liberty has raised
questions about it too many left-wingers
are not comfortable with it
they say it's going to create an unequal
society a two-track society
and that it's yet another infringement
upon our rights so
just to go back to my earlier point
we're all reporting it because it's
news but my suspicion is that over the
few days you're going to hear some
critical voices about this plan
particularly rachel let's have a look at
the front of the
sunday express same story pm brighter
days ahead boris unveils jabs
passport to reopen uh britain and of
course uh
israel has used one very successfully i
did an interview only yesterday with
someone in israel who says that it's
been pretty seamless there was a bit of
uh complaining at the start but now
everyone's got used to it and one of the
things that he has done
is encouraged young people to get the
vaccine so that they
can then go and enjoy a nice house
well uh that may well have been the case
in israel but i don't think that's
necessarily a given
uh with this vaccine passport in fact
the bmj
just had a piece the other day saying
this isn't how you encourage
positive behavior or you know vaccine
uptake that
actually making things compulsory can
have the the opposite effect
and you know the reason that um many
voices on the left
do oppose the idea of a vaccine passport
is because it it's
it's discrimination effectively um the
vaccine rollout has not been
equal in this society the uptake has
has been along uh pre-existing lines of
inequality
in this country areas of deprivation
minority ethnic communities
and so it amounts to discrimination
if you are then making it compulsory for
entrance to various events and i think
that
um you know when we look at the best way
to prevent
outbreaks going forward we mentioned
that tim mentioned the test and trace
system and how that was a bit of a white
elephant well
that is the way to get out of lockdown
and stay out of lockdown
um you know that's the way to squash out
breaks if they happen so that we can
you know not be forced into more
restrictive measures and it is
extraordinary
that we stopped talking about a system
which has cost us billions of pounds
which
the house of commons um public affairs
committee said
had no negligible effect
on uh tracing um and it
just seems staggering that instead of
fixing that
the government is going off and spending
money on yeah what sounds like
another white elephant rachel sorry to
it sorry to interrupt but isn't it only
discriminatory against people who are
positive
because if you get a passport if you've
had the vaccine if you've got antibodies
or you've tested negative then the only
people
who aren't allowed into a sports venue
for example are people who are testing
positive you shouldn't be going anywhere
well lots of people aren't getting
tested because
they can't afford to self-isolate and
take time off work
if they test positive in fact that's one
of the main reasons
why people who are not going for tests
even if they have symptoms
and that and that will that will
discriminate against people who you know
if you can't afford to self-isolate
that is discrimination if you're then
making entrance to events compulsory
yeah i suppose we don't have a system
yet that can give you a very accurate
very fast test
outside a venue uh we're still told that
is round the corner
um interesting in the express it says
they're going to do a trial in a
liverpool comedy club which should give
plenty material uh for those on the
stage i would have thought
tim in the sunday times their headline
no passport needed for a pint
in the pub there has been a huge amount
of controversy hasn't there especially
from the
hospitality sector saying that why
should they be policing this
it has been suggested that there's been
a lot of pushback from the hospitality
sector because they say as you said
they can't police us but obviously it's
also going to put people off going out
the idea that you might
take a test in order that you can go to
the pub well most people would just
decide not to go to the park that's an
awful faff
um just to take us back to the telegraph
i i find it very interesting that
michael gove has written a piece for us
when she talks about having a
conversation with the public
about the role of covert certification
even though it's obviously going to
happen in some form it is being rolled
out
i mean the tories are sensitive as with
pubs and restaurants they're sensitive
to areas where people feel this should
not be done
and they're still slightly testing the
waters over it it is going to happen but
there's clearly some
that they are conscious of some unease
about the policy
and how easily it might be applied and
rachel raises a very good point
um about whether or not this is going to
be equitable
because don't forget that a big story in
the background is
for instance the huge disparity between
people on the basis of race as to
whether or not
they have been immunized well if you if
you then say
okay you can only go to this venue if
you have taken the test if you've
had it or you have been immunized then
potentially you're opening the ground
for a certain amount of discrimination
there or at least you're sort of
embedding discrimination there
this should make people i feel very
uncomfortable because traditionally this
is not a country where you have to show
your papers that's not something you do
yes you have to show id for all sorts of
things the reality is you do have to do
that nowadays opening a bank account
uh getting an internet setup and what
sort of thing but the idea that in your
everyday life to go to a football match
or
uh to go to a comedy isn't it a small
price to pay to just receive
a small price to pay given the
extraordinary situation we're in and
only
going to last perhaps for for a few
months
well so they say uh but these things
once you bring them in they're very
difficult to get rid of and if it is
only gonna last for a few months i come
back to the point i made at the
beginning if you're rolling this out in
september or october
when the vast majorities have been
immunized anyway what is the point of
doing
it immunization is reducing transmission
that's the way out of this
i i don't really understand why this is
necessary except of course to save
certain large-scale events taking place
over the summer but again
if it's not going to be in place until
september october yeah
it wouldn't do that no no good point
okay rachel tim
fascinating discussion uh do state there
for the moment coming up could there be
an early election in may
2023 gosh labour leader sakirshama has
asked his party to prepare for one
that's coming up
tim why don't you start things off this
half and the front of the
observer we've not looked at the
observer yet a couple of stories here
first of all uh the protests in bristol
women's anger and abuse of power
in police raids talk us through this
that's right the police have been
accused of abusing their power
in the raids over the kill the bill just
to quote one
astonishing example from the observer kt
mcgorran 21 who left the first kill the
bill demonstration on the 21st of march
before any trouble broke out
claimed she was mistakenly arrested
after a male officer dressed as a
postman
tricked his way into her shared student
house in north
bristol five days later this sort of
thing is absolutely astonishing and
one of the the real tragedies over all
of this is that
some of these protests were inspired of
course by the sarah everard case and
um by which is a story about violence
against women
and the idea that the police now stand
accused of using bullying authoritarian
or even deceptive tactics
in order to police women is a really
very tragic coder to that story
yeah rachel because you get your
thoughts on this another story we're
running this evening about police
breaking up a church service on
good friday i mean these stories do get
highlighted and the media is all over
them
um how are you viewing our
police right now
um well it's interesting to see the
scale of the protests and today was
another day of
you know i think in 24 towns and cities
there were thousands of people
protesting
um the police bill
which of course is an authoritarian
crackdown
on protests currently making its way
through parliament
a lot of these protests are very
youth-led there's absolute outrage
about this attempts by this government
to to shut down protest and of course
that then the government sort of
signaling about this whole
issue is essentially signaling to the
police
uh that they have the backing of the
government and i think that
to a certain degree the police brutality
that we're seeing at these protests and
to be clear that
is what we are seeing absolutely
appalling
um policing um in particular
these two women who are cited in this
observer piece
you know it's it's straight up abusive
power the way these two women have been
treated
and so we do have to see it in that
context of the way the government has
been behaving
and particularly this bill uh that seeks
to silence protesters
yeah just hearing that uh 26 people have
been arrested by the metropolitan police
service
today uh 10 officers slightly uh injured
we're hearing and let's finish uh with
this story also on the front of the
observer tim about kierstarma it's
monday marks a year of kia and uh he's
saying get ready for an early election
he's saying that he's also saying that
he's going to take the mask off and take
the fight to the people
it's about time he's got to do that and
i i feel somewhat sorry for secure
because
he launched his leadership at the worst
possible political moment covert took
over and that's the dominant story
and people say he's not doing a very
good job his polling is bad
but right now it's almost like a
falklands moment for this government
whether
you like it or not the reality is is
that the public is rallying around it
and is rewarding it for its vaccine
success
and it's very hard to imagine what any
labor leader could do
under those circumstances to really make
an impression
nevertheless he's got to obviously come
up with a stronger message to people
because
he's right now not cutting through
simply being
not jeremy corbyn doesn't seem to be
winning him enough votes
yeah rachel just about uh 30 seconds to
get your thoughts on this
on those two allegations really firstly
that he's not been critical enough of
the government
and secondly he's not been clear enough
about what he stands for
yeah i agree with both those things i do
think that you know throughout this year
of the pandemic we've had
extremely high death toll one of the
highest in the world and we've got the
worst
economic recovery of the g7 there's
millions of people up and down this
country
in desperate need of an opposition that
will stand up and speak for them and
fight for them
on that front i think the labour
leadership has been woefully lacking
okay rachel tim thank you both very much
indeed